well as you know entertains the worst
influence to ever come into the world so
the schools have to re-educate boys from
the brainwashing that Tate did
let's get it uh you've heard of uh hate
speech well Tate speech is spreading a
toxic cloud through Schools
teachers are re-educating boys
brainwashed by Andrew Tate now if you
don't know who Andrew Titus and I really
didn't and it was my young nieces 14 and
11 who told me oh Carla they said like
it's what they call me auntie uh you
don't know he is a terrible misogynistic
man and we don't like him
what is this picture they they're using
of him in bed with a sword oh my God
that's hilarious you've heard of hate
speech now have you heard of T like I
can't believe I don't know this is the
news I don't know what uh level or
quality of British British News Network
this is seems pretty legit well it looks
legitimate that doesn't mean it's right
and you know you can really see um why
Greta thumbberg told him to write to her
at get a life this is not his Tinder and
he's a big machete in history you really
need to know anything are they still
they're just keeping the the camera on
this angle starting sheets and a machete
with sunglasses yes you'll see a pool I
mean he couldn't try harder it's um well
he's an influencer and and the problem
is he has been influencing a lot of
teenagers yeah so what teachers are now
having to do in schools are they
confronting his Mrs misogynistic
Manifesto alliteration everybody
is my first language a misogynistic
Manifesto I don't know what does that
even mean whenever there's a mass
killing of any sort they usually find
this Manifesto that the killer wrote
which is basically like along a document
a paper a diary where they talk about
their philosophy and why they do what
they do so it's as if he has a massage a
a paper that he wrote on misogyny that
he uses in order to teach misogyny woman
hating that's what she's implying let's
see that's funny I like the lingo she's
used to be Spike lessons and I I think
normally I would say organization at all
intervene but it is so vile and he has
really
um influenced young boys into thinking
really vile things like um you know
women are there for for sex women are
there to be in the kitchen I can't even
you know it's this toxic masculinity
that he's promoting and what's quite
worrying about it this thing called
hospice University which essentially was
a pyramid oh my God this is so funny I
can't believe people watch the news for
credible information anymore it's really
sad it makes me so sad to see that
people will see this won't do any of
their own research they'll consider this
research that's the crazy thing if you
get to talking to somebody they'll be
like well I saw it on the news yeah
we'll look deeper right side on two
different news stations so I did
research no that's not research that's
propaganda consumption yeah I know the
sad thing is that these people I do
believe it like these journalists
probably are being honest and they do
believe stuff that they're saying like
yeah he was a bad man with the pyramid
scheme stealing money from friends and
brainwash them like do you think that
everyone's that dumb to just be like
completely brainwashed by this guy that
um yeah he's just taking all our money
teaching us nothing and that's it it is
an insult to the young men yeah they're
just like yeah us young men we're so
stupid that we need to listen to you
well there are also young men who are
literally giving up their masculinity at
the altar of feminism so you know we see
this happening so we do see young men
being tricked into dumb so it's not
Beyond you know it's not Beyond
Comprehension that people will be dumb
and follow dumb leaders no follow bad
leaders so because we see it but you
know for them to to have such just
slanted Tick Tock
education on Andrew Tate before they
speak about him it is a tick tock
education we're partnering up with a
Navy SEAL friend of ours Tom Shea host a
21 day virtual event that you guys can
join with us Tom is going to teach you
how to listen to your mind in a new way
and how to control it so that you can
have the discipline you need to build
the life you want so I've seen this
process done for 30 years when you make
it through you will be a different human
being the process is simple but not easy
because of the war that's inside of us
that few people have been taught to
fight overcoming your excuses so if
you're interested in becoming a reformed
human an absolute animal go to
tomshay.com and use Sunny fast50 for 50
off of this program you will not regret
it you will be a changed person at the
end of it do not miss this he was you
spread Andrew Tate's content and what he
does is that he sort of goes in with the
whole hey you can make a big living you
can be the big dog and he goes in with
that and so these people so listen to it
go yeah yeah I can be the big dog I can
like um
but then he slips in the misogyny well
this is the thing I'm yeah I I mean
let's see what happens because he's
currently uh in prison in Romania let's
find out if he is a human sex trafficker
or not we don't know that yet
um but I've been listening to some of
his long-form interviews I'm really
interested in this because I I for me
too yeah personally very interested in
all this anti-male stuff I don't think
it's good I think if boys are dropping
out of education and all that stuff what
you don't want is is some hero to appear
that's going to cause trouble so I've
been listening to some like a lot of
what he's got to say I listened to an
hour and a half of him and Piers Morgan
yeah I saw that one listen to two it was
fascinated so I've really got a sense of
the guy and it's like it's like going
into a restaurant and having a really
fancy meal but there's a turd in it
because a lot of what he says is is
really interesting it's about commitment
and training and all that sort of he
contradicts himself he will say one
minute that um you should uh commit and
you and being in a commitment committed
relationship is brilliant and you and
you should really do it and then the
next he'll say that women are all
and that they're all sleeping around and
you can and you can get it he doesn't
even say that yeah I've never heard him
say that I like this blonde lady because
she has already proven that she I may
not agree with everything she says but
she has already proven that she took the
time and this other one based on the
language language she's using like top
dog like you said clearly she didn't
she's never seen a video what a producer
put some Tick Tock videos in front of
her she formed an opinion and she's
going on the air yeah what I don't
understand she's like I agree with most
of what he says and then there's a turd
in it it's like you don't agree with
everything anybody says like there's
nobody you agree with everything they
say yeah it's just like another normal
person like it's just another normal
thing where you agree with the law and
then you disagree with some right
that's it like what is so crazy that is
they they have these people and they
they put people in these absolute silos
where you are in a you're now in a
category based on the one worst thing
you ever said or did crazy no matter how
many you know thousands and thousands of
wonderful things you said or did or
positive influence you had the one thing
you said or did and this is what they do
this I mean but it's it's gotten to the
point where I think more and more people
are waking up and looking at the news
and going shut up well yeah what do you
think I'm an idiot I'm done with your
like we're done listening to
the to propaganda because everyone that
likes Tate isn't isn't going to stop
liking him because these bimbos go off
saying that he's misogynist no but they
can now Recruit new people who never
heard of him to automatically dislike
him yeah yeah and that's troubling yeah
I know guys that dislike him
soy boys
yes he does because he says you can get
a practice girl and you just do this
yeah but he but it's worse than that the
stuff that he says I wish I had an
actual quote right now you are
struggling to find it I I heard it I
wonder whether it's all been abandoned
yeah the thing is she's saying she's
struggling to find these these bad Clips
you're talking about yes that's what
that's what I thought I heard yeah
that's she went looking for she went
looking for the devil and she can't find
him yeah that's funny and that's
interesting everything is that he is he
is quite captivating to listen just from
someone like obviously yourself and
myself you know we don't agree I'm sorry
I'm not saying pain to that but he was
interesting to listen to It's like at
the moment I'm like want to scream at
home like what the hell and then there's
other times if you're a young 14 year
old boy and this is what's happened he's
captivated and someone's described it as
a version of radicalization and that's
exactly what extremists do and this is
no different basically just someone that
has influence and you don't like that
they have influence and not you anymore
that's basically what it is
so funny he's they bought into this this
magnetic man and thinking that this
lifestyle is like well I don't want to
go to school people and kids are
dropping out of school as you say yeah
the website is very child it's def I
mean that picture's nothing I looked at
the website and the graphics I mean it's
comic it's it's aimed at young young
boys and the problem is they're aimed at
young boys it seems at young men is he
is she talking about um is Hustler's
University website yeah she you know
when you say young boys you're implying
children I know the guy that that built
this yeah this this is not I don't know
this is W branding shout out shout out
it's his branding this Islam this isn't
childlike as she's implying yeah this is
this is just a solid website when did
show when did go down a little bit uh
right there like go up like copywriting
freelancing e-commerce Amazon FBA
artificial intelligence what little kids
are going into that no I mean even if it
is young men young even teenagers young
teenagers 13 and up looking at that that
means they're looking at getting
entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial education and they're
making it sound like this is a bad thing
where does it say smack a on here
can you help me find that part I
couldn't tell you yeah I really feel for
the teachers who are trying to combat
this because I remember being at school
I went to school there was a boy who I
won't name him uh he did a bomb scare on
the school it was a lot of
kids like naughty things yeah I have
been at my school and I don't know
actually my this might like backfire
because obviously if you ban or we could
try and stop something
kids they will go more towards it the
more difficult one the ground that was
stupid yeah that was just I don't know
why people listen to women hey
no that's stupid I'm just joking I know
I'm not gonna listen that was some that
was some garbage ass news yeah it was
basically exactly what I thought it
would be like what is except for that
one chick but but she even said she said
I feel for the teachers right she
started with I can't even find any the
really harsh stuff that you're saying he
said and then she's saying I feel for
the teachers who are combating this
stuff so she had to like stay on task in
order to keep her job yeah should end on
a negative note what are you combating
entrepreneurial Spirit ambition the
desire to learn and grow and build
Financial stability and generational
wealth for your family so you don't have
to live on the government Dole so you
can have true Freedom these are things
that they're combating could you imagine
we've come to this what's going on it's
crazy well everyone can have the
entrepreneurial Spirit or nothing would
get done we need the slave Minds for
society to function which is the
craziest part of it all because it all
makes perfect sense we're still gonna
have the slave Minds because there are
people who have simpleton brains and
that's okay that them have it but if
somebody has a has a good brain and they
want to create stop with the fire if
they want to create something that will
give all the the simpletons a place to
earn a living and get better get less
simple all right I'm not on the
simpletons everybody calm down we should
be nice to them where do you look at
when you look at the camera what do you
look at I look right at the camera in
the lens you like the middle round part
am I looking at the wrong part no it
just doesn't look like I'm looking here
and it looks like you're just like
call loopy thank you guys so much for
watching
make sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram at sunnyfaz and um if you'd
like a free preview of how I've
generated five million dollars using
organic marketing you can join my
Discord for free
see you guys
[Music]